supporters of president trump were  making the push in person  trying to get as many people as possible  registered to vote traditionally the  deadline to register is about a month  before the election  however in the state of nevada you are  allowed to register and vote on election  day  or during early voting you can also make  changes to your existing registration at  any voting site  it's as simple as just filling out a  form and everyone should do it there's  no real reason no good excuse not to you  know  this country doesn't operate unless  everyone you know unless we have people  participate  and it's important that everybody get  out and register  and a reminder 8 news now is your local  election headquarters you can find  updates on the presidential election  both on air and online at eight newsnow  dot com